Die eu-kommission hat die überprüfung der sommerzeit gestartet jetzt haben bürger aus der ganzen eu die gelegenheit die sommerzeit zu beurteilen und gegebenenfalls
abzulehnen wir hatten ja schon über die sinnlosigkeit und die verrückten umstände berichtet die zur einführung geführt hatten heute übrigens
klicks um science-fiction aus dem bett mir geht es nur so semi also herzlich willkommen
Hier du wir zusammen können etwas ändern gerade haben wir es ja bei der neuregelung des urheberrechts in der eu gezeigt
und ihr hier bei pixum habt mit eurem protest
demonstriert dass er nicht alles mit euch machen lasst die
upload filter sind jetzt erstmal vom tisch und wenn das gesetz dann im september neu beraten wird dann dürfte es
erhebliche veränderungen geben vielen dank dafür an euch
ihr seid mit dafür verantwortlich und jetzt geht es um die sommerzeit und die könnt ihr auch abschaffen
die sommerzeit ist nämlich sinnlos das erste mal wurde sie ja von deutschland und österreich-ungarn während des ersten weltkrieges eingeführt weil man sich da durch
energieeinsparung versprach mit der eingesparten energie
damals wurden städte noch mit gas beleuchtet strom mit kohle hergestellt
wollte man diese rohstoffe für das militär einsparen doch dass man durch das ausnutzen der hellen
morgenstunden mehr energie einspart ist mehr als umstritten
im gegenteil alle bekannten untersuchungen kommen zu dem ergebnis dass der minderverbrauch zu
vernachlässigen ist das ergebnis war meistens das zwar weniger künstliche beleuchtung benötigt wird aber
mehr geheizt wird
2005 fasste die bundesregierung diese erkenntnisse noch mal in einer antwort auf eine kleine anfrage der fdp fraktion
zusammen und heute dürften die auswirkungen sogar umgekehrt seien dadurch dass die beleuchtung
deutlich weniger energie verbraucht als noch vor zehn jahren
dürfte der effekt inzwischen umgekehrt sein wir dürften also durch das verstärkte heizen mehr energie verbrauchen aber
darüber gibt es keinerlei erkenntnisse
oh mann doch die
energieeinsparungen sind heute gar nicht mal mehr der grund für die einführung der sommerzeit
jetzt kommt mit das verrückte der eigentliche grund ist die harmonisierung derzeit in europa um den handel zu erleichtern
so steht es explizit in der stellungnahme der bundesregierung
als sophie bitte noch mal ganz langsam die sommerzeit gibt es weil sie andere mal eingeführt haben vollkommen ohne grund
und wir uns jetzt in europa nach diesen ländern richten obwohl es gar keinen sinn macht
ja und dabei sind die gesundheitlichen folgen noch nicht berücksichtigt viele menschen beklagen
schlafstörungen schlappheit und eine schwedische studie kommt sogar zu dem ergebnis dass in den tagen nach der zeitumstellung
mehr menschen einen herzinfarkt erleiden und genau deshalb macht die eu-kommission jetzt dazu eine umfrage
hierbei whatsapp habe ich euch ja dazu befragt und das ergebnis war eindeutig von
4234 befragten stimmten
78,9 prozent dagegen
eine überwältigende mehrheit er sieht also schlecht aus für die sommerzeit und das ist auch gut so
in der befragung können die bürger zudem entscheiden ob sie eine ständige
winter oder eine ständige sommerzeit wollen ihr könnt jetzt also wieder die politik
mitbestimmen legt los der link zur befragung ist in der video beschreibung oder er bekommt ihn per whatsapp
womit wir beim thema wären wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet nicht bei whatsapp
darum geht ihr die kaputte abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert einfach
hier draufklicken
und am besten auf meinen schwester cara klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt da ist auch
der link hier und nicht die glocke vergessen natürlich moment nicht die
blogger vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit auch irgendwo da
wird die sommerzeit abgeschafft also drauf klicken wenn er sehen wollt bis dann
bleibt kann